[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Thank
you for joining us today.
Today, my colleague
Wyatt and I are
going to talk about
high-performance computing
on Google Cloud.
My name is Emma.
I'm a developer advocate
for Google Cloud Platform.
So we have four chapters today.
The first part is about
reviewing what HPC is
and what it means on Cloud.
And then we'd like to talk about
some of the Cloud offerings
we have for HPC applications.
Then Wyatt be discussing
job management on Cloud
and some of the
real-world case studies.
So let's take a close
look at what HPC is
and what it means on Cloud.
High-performance
computing, or HPC,
is generally characterized
as massively parallel
and with a lot of data.
So massively parallel
means a lot of cores
from tens of thousands
of cores and sometimes
hundreds of thousands of cores.
A lot of data usually means
petabytes, sometimes exabytes,
of data.
HPC is one of the most important
areas in computer science.
It powers a lot of
different industry,
such as scientific
simulations, engineering,
financial services, health and
life science, data analysis
and more.
So these are just
a few examples.
But when you think of
high-performance computing,
there are actually two slightly
different types of workloads.
The first kind,
or the first type,
is high throughput
or what we call
embarrassingly
parallel computing.
So these types of workloads
are relatively independently
working on each node, so they
communicate less often or less
often between nodes.
The example, types of workloads
include financial services,
genomics, media transcoding,
rendering, and data analysis.
So these types of workloads
just works fine on Cloud
today, and there are
a lot of examples.
The other type of workload
is tightly coupled
or just parallel computing.
This is more of the
traditional area
in high-performance computing.
Applications might use MPI
as a programming interface.
They often communicate
between nodes,
so they require low-latency,
high-bandwidth network
and, of course, they also
require a lot of storage,
and they must be fast enough.
So this is more about scientific
engineering computation.
Example use cases
are computation
of fluid dynamics, electronics,
engineering and product
design, oil and gas
research, weather, physics,
and chemistry.
We actually have a lot of
real-use cases and customers
running these two
types of workloads,
including the
high-throughput computing
and tightly-coupled computing.
And while we showcasing some of
the examples during this talk.
HPC requires a quite different
kind of infrastructure when
compared to web applications
or mobile backhands.
Of course, it requires a
strong computation power
and a lot of storage.
And as they communicate
between nodes,
they require low-latency
and high-bandwidth network.
And as we will need to
manage all of the nodes,
we need some sort of software
to manage these HPC deployments.
And of course, we need
to be cost friendly.
Why would we need to use
Cloud or migrate to Cloud?
Well, in the world of
on-premise HPC clusters,
we usually have
relatively smaller number
of configurations.
For example, we might have
a single configuration
of nodes with CPUs and GPUs
and the same amount of memory
for all of the nodes.
So they usually have one or a
few queues so all of the users
have to use the same
configuration, the same queue.
Sometimes these machines
are too big or too small
for these workloads, so there
are some computation resources
that are left unused.
But with Cloud, you can
configure as many clusters
or as many queues as you need.
And on top of that, you can
resize these virtual machines
as necessary and add SSDs
or GPUs as necessary.
For example, if some of
your users need just CPUs,
we can set up a
cluster with CPUs.
And if another user
might need GPUs,
we can add GPUs
just for the user.
So these are more resource
efficient and cost efficient.
And of course, these clusters
can be scaled in and out
as necessary.
And we can go even farther.
For example, when your
task needs exactly 20 CPUs
and 46-gigabytes memory, we
can provision virtual machines
of the exact size.
We call it custom machine types.
We'll explain later,
but this is the idea
of having virtual machines and
computation nodes on Cloud.
So let me introduce some
of the Cloud offerings
we have for HPC applications.
Compute Engine.
The Compute Engine is one of
the most fundamental components
on Google Cloud.
They're high-performance
virtual machines with access
to the latest
generations of hardware,
including Intel's Skylake
processors and NVIDIA's Volta
GPUs.
They are very easy to provision.
They can be started within
10 seconds or 20 seconds.
So when you are
starting 100 nodes,
they will be ready
within a minute.
And we have the web interface
command line utility
and web API, so you can start
using the Cloud with the web
interface.
And when you need to
automate certain tasks,
you can migrate to other
methods to control your cluster.
Of course, we take security
very, very seriously.
We have more than 750 engineers
and security experts working
to protect our infrastructure.
They're not only
working on the software
we run on our platform, but
also the hardware network
and physical infrastructure.
So they're designing
and engineering
all aspects of our platform.
And we use the same network.
We have one of the strongest
network for public cloud
providers.
We the same network
for Google Cloud
that we use for our services
like YouTube, Search, Maps,
and all other applications.
So running your
application on Google Cloud
means you will be benefited from
the network and infrastructure
that we use to run our services.
These are some of the
numbers and details.
So Compute Engine
is very flexible--
from 1 core to 160 cores, and
you can scale up to nearly 4
terabytes of memory.
And you can, of course, attach
GPUs and SSDs as necessary.
And you can configure
preemptible VMs and GPUs.
These are mechanisms
to save costs.
I'll explain this part
more in detail later.
Since this is very
flexible, you can
install any operating systems
or any software that you
need to run your software.
So Compute Engine can be
used for MPI applications,
batch-HTC applications,
real-time processing,
MapReduce, and machine
learning workloads.
So this is a very flexible.
Having access to latest
generation of hardware
is even more
important with Cloud.
With Intel Skylake
CPUs, your application
might run faster by
up to 82% with access
to the AVX-512 instructions.
Shorter runtime means not only
you get your results faster
but also, you can terminate
these instances earlier,
so you don't have to
pay for the idling time
and wasted the
computing resources.
We have GPUs as well.
You can attach up to eight
GPUs per virtual machine.
They're directly attached
to these virtual machines
via PCI express,
so they are close
to the bare-metal performance.
And GPUs also [INAUDIBLE]
preemptible's virtual machines.
We offer NVIDIA Tesla K80,
P100, and the latest Volta V100.
We have a couple of
blocks switch options.
The first option
is the local SSD.
They are directly attached
to the virtual machines.
There are ephemeral, so
when virtual machines
are terminating, the data
on this storage will lost.
But it is very fast with
680 kilo IOPS for read
and 2.5 gigabits per
second of throughput.
You can attach up to 3 terabytes
of SSDs to a single instance.
This is best to be
used for temporary data
and other frequently
access scratch space.
We also have persistent
disks with SSDs and HTDs.
So as the name implies,
these are persistent.
So even when virtual
machines are terminated,
the data will be kept.
SSDs are best for latency
sensitive applications
and data.
They have up to 40k read
IOPS and 100 megabytes power
read of throughput.
Hard disks are very
cost effective.
It is best suited for latency
insensitive tasks and lots
of data.
Both of these
persistent disks can
be scaled up to use 64
terabytes per instance.
And we offer other features
such as Snapshots, encryptions,
and others to protect your data.
We also, for objects storage--
Cloud Storage-- for
large unstructured data.
These can scale up
to exabytes and can
be accessed from any of
the virtual machines,
and even from outside of
a Google Cloud Platform
with the REST interface.
The latency with
the objects storage
is higher than persistent
disks, so they're more
suited for bulk operations.
We offer POSIX-compliant
storage with gscfuse,
so you can mount
these storage buckets
from your Linux instances.
We have some of
the best networks.
You can launch up to
7,000 virtual machines
in a single network.
And they have relatively
predictable low latency
between nodes, with
40 to 60 microseconds.
The bandwidth depends
on the number of cores.
They can scale up to
16 gigabits per second.
So this is faster than
10-gigabit ethernet.
And in order to achieve
this performance,
we design our data center
network from scratch.
We use closed approach network
so that these nodes can
communicate to other nodes
relatively regardless
of their physical positions.
Not only the intra-data
center network,
we also have a global
Google network.
So you will seeing this
diagram before I think.
But these blue lines
are existing cables
that Google uses,
and these green lines
are new optic fiber cables
that we invest in and build
with our partners.
So when you are working
with other institutions
and working on
international projects,
you can move your data from
one continent to another.
We offer options to save cost.
Custom machine types--
I talked about this
briefly before.
This is a mechanism to
pick any configuration that
matches your workloads.
This is as easy as moving these
slides in the web interface.
You can choose from
1 core to 106 cores
very easily by moving the slides
and the same for the memory.
Our customers have saved an
average of 90% or up to 50%
by using custom machine types.
So this is about choosing the
right size of virtual machines
for your workloads.
These numbers are from the
real customer examples.
And we also, for preemptive
virtual machine instances,
they are discounted
by up to 80%,
so they are super low
cost, short-term instances.
So they might get preempted.
So they have the maximum
lifetime of 24 hours.
They might run up to 24 hours
but they are not guaranteed
to be alive for 24 hours.
We might have to
terminate them, but they
are discounted in return.
And we have reduced pricing
for attached resources,
such as local SSDs and GPUs.
So if you run preemptible
VMs, your attached resources
are also discounted.
And we even, with
preemptible VMs,
you have access to the
same set of hardware
that we offer for regular VMs.
So this is best suited for
relatively shorter lifetime
tasks and high-throughput
computing or independent jobs
kind of tasks.
They can either be
started again from scratch
or can be resumed
from checkpoints.
So even if you have to
run the same task again,
they are discounted farther.
So in total, you can save cost.
Now, I'd like to welcome Wyatt
to talk about job management
and real-use cases on Cloud.
WYATT GORMAN: Hi, everybody.
Thank you, Emma.
So Emma's just given
us a great overview
of the infrastructure
that we could
use to build high-performance
computing clouds.
So I want to talk now about
how we can run and manage jobs
on those high-performance
computing clusters
in the Cloud, what
software we can use--
I want to give you all a
couple of opportunities
to get your hands
dirty, so if you
want to take your laptops
out, I have a couple of links
so you can load up some
codelabs and tutorials--
and then I want to talk
about some real world
customer-use cases where we've
seen our customers running
their high-performance computing
applications in the cloud.
So we have a number of
workload management partners.
So first of all, what
is a workload manager
in high-performance computing?
In traditional high-performance
computing, a workload manager,
their job is pretty much
limited to managing resources
and allocating jobs
throughout a cluster.
So that means that you
build your cluster,
you configure it with your
operating system, everything
like that, and then you
install a workload manager
on top of that.
And then you use that workload
manager to submit jobs,
and that workload manager
allocates those jobs
throughout the cluster to manage
those resources and best bin
pack it's called, right?
So in the Cloud, the role
of a workload manager
expands a little bit often.
And so they often take
on the responsibility
of building the cluster,
provisioning the nodes,
configuring the nodes even,
and everything like that.
Those are the sorts of
things that you can't
do with hardware and software.
So they even extend often to
scheduling maintenance tasks
and tearing down
nodes as needed.
So we have a number of
partners, as I said.
I want to just focus
on three of them today.
So the three we have today
are Altair's PBScloud.io.
This is a really easy-to-use,
web-based management system.
We have SchedMD Slurm,
and we also have HTCondor.
So for the people
who are here, who's
used these pieces of software
somewhere on premise already?
Just a few people.
Great.
This is an intro course, so
you're all in the right place.
Who's used it on
the Cloud, though--
any of these pieces of software?
A couple of hands went up
that didn't go up earlier.
That's great.
Warms my heart.
So I'm hoping to get everybody's
hands up by the end of this
because we have a couple
of tutorials and codelabs
we can do.
So first of all is
Altair's PBScloud.
For anybody who isn't
familiar with Altair,
they're a company
that develops software
for things like
computational fluid dynamics,
structural simulations
for engineering,
crash simulations in
automotive and military uses.
So they have this
suite of software,
and they really wanted
to build a system that
would allow their customers
to run these jobs very easily
using the Cloud resources.
So what they built
was PBScloud.io,
and they built it on GCP.
So PBScloud.io, like I said,
is a very simple-to-use,
web-based GUI where you can log
in, when you log in you provide
a Google Cloud
Platform billing ID--
so that's the only tie-back
you really have to Google Cloud
to know that you're
running on Google Cloud.
So you provide this
billing ID, and then
you get a menu of possible
solvers, Altair software,
and others, and you can
provide your input data,
you can provide the way
you want the job to scale,
any limits or anything like
that you want to apply,
and click launch.
And it will go and
spin up the nodes,
it'll show you that
it's spinning them up,
configuring them, and
then actually allocating
your job across those nodes.
Tear the whole
thing down once it's
done, provide your output data
into a Google Cloud Storage
bucket, for example.
So this is a really,
really easy way
to get started
with some workloads
that you already have
that are independent.
So you can go and
log on to PBScloud.io
today, provide your billing
ID, and start launching jobs.
So that's a very simple
way to get going.
That's not typical
in HPC though.
So Slurm is another more
traditional HPC workload
manager.
It's very popular.
It's open source.
It's used in some of the largest
high-performance computing
clusters in the world.
And so we partnered
with SchedMD,
who are the developers
and maintainers of Slurm,
to bring Google Cloud native
functionality and integrations
into the Slurm Workload Manager.
And so we announced this
at SuperComputing 2017.
These integrations are
available on Slurm's GitHub,
so if you wanted to
Google them right
now you could go and
look at all the code.
And so there are three ways
to use these integrations.
The first is a standalone
auto-scaling cluster
in the Cloud.
The second is a burst
to cloud use case where
you have an existing controller
as an existing Slurm cluster,
and you can actually spin up
independent VMs in a cloud
project and run jobs
on them as needed.
And the third is a
federate-to-cloud use case
that's really popular, and
I'll talk about the Cloud
auto-scaling and federate
to cloud a little bit more.
But for anybody who
wants to get started,
this is the link right there.
You can load that up.
That's a codelab--
a Google codelab--
that will guide you through
setting up a project,
downloading the
Slurm integrations,
and configuring them
and launching a cluster,
and then even scaling
it to meet demand
or you could search
"Google Slurm Codelab."
Everybody got that?
Got your pictures?
Great.
So its just down
here at the bottom if
anybody needs as well.
So in a Cloud auto-scaling
implementation,
its like I said-- a standalone
cluster in the cloud.
So what does that mean?
It means you have a login node,
as is traditional in any HPC
cluster, you want an independent
login node that isn't actually
doing any work so
that if it goes down
when you're SSHed into
it for some reason,
nothing's affected.
So you have a login
node, a controller node--
that's the node that's
actually running the Slurm
controller, the Slurm
database, the Slurm accounting
daemon, and everything like that
that everything reports back
into to get its job allocation.
And then you have
the compute nodes.
So all of these are running
on Google Compute Engine.
And so the cluster auto-scales
according to two parameters--
it scales up and down.
So the parameters are,
first, job requirements.
So if any one job is submitted
that needs more resources
than the cluster
currently has, it
will spin up resources
to accommodate that.
So for example, if you had
a cluster of two nodes--
two compute nodes, for example--
and you submitted a single
job that required four nodes,
it'll spin up those
two additional nodes,
integrate them into the
cluster, and allocate the job
to those four nodes.
The second is queue depth.
So this isn't something
that a lot of people
think about very often.
But if you were to submit,
say, four single-node jobs,
each job only requiring
at most one node,
then a workload manager
might just allocate them
all to the same node.
Depending on your
over-subscription settings
in Slurm though, you can scale
to meet that so those four
jobs would spin up into
additional two nodes
to meet the four nodes that were
required by each of those four
jobs.
It's a very dynamic scaling
to meet requirements.
And then like I said, it spins
them down as well afterwards.
So according to an
adjustable idle timeout,
the nodes will be deprovisioned
and deleted in Google Cloud
after the nodes are
idle so that you're not
paying for any unneeded,
unnecessary usage
or compute time.
The best part of all this is
that once you deploy the Slurm
cluster in the Cloud,
for anybody who's
used Slurm before,
it's the same tools
that you used before, it's
the same tools that your users
and admins are used to, so it's
really easy to get started.
The second use case is the
federate-to-cloud use case.
This is where we see a
lot of customers going
for their burst-to-cloud needs.
So in a Slurm federation, you're
able to add multiple clusters
into what's called a
federation and distribute jobs
amongst them.
So you combine all
of these clusters,
you actually use a single
accounting master server
for all of the Slurm
accounting, which
makes things like Slurm
account management
as well as job placement
policies and things
like that, which are
very powerful in Slurm.
Makes it really easy to manage
all those from a single master
server.
And then you can actually
manually assign jobs
to independent clusters.
If, for example, you knew
one user was supposed
to run on just one
cluster, you can
mandate that they only
run on that cluster
or you can allow the federation
to allocate that job.
And how that works is that the
federation actually submits
the job to all the clusters.
So all the clusters
get a view of this job,
and whichever cluster responds
that it can allocate the job
the fastest is given that job,
and all the other clusters
delete that job replica.
So a great way to distribute
jobs automatically
according to whatever is
able to respond quickest.
So this is really
great, like I said,
for burst-to-cloud use cases.
A lot of customers have
already started doing that.
And it's really
easy to get started.
It's literally one line in
your Slurm configuration,
you restart the daemons,
and you're up and running.
So it's really easy
to get started.
There will be
codelab on Federation
that's linked from the
auto-scaling codelab
as well very shortly.
Another example is HTCondor.
So this is a really
popular workload manager
that's specifically designed
for high throughput computing--
the kind of high
throughput computing
that Emma introduced earlier.
And so it's really
easily deployed
on Google Cloud Platform
using our Deployment Manager.
So we have a tutorial
there at that link.
You can also just Google search
"Google HTCondor Tutorial,"
and it'll walk you
through the whole process
of downloading the
deployment manager scripts,
installing them, and
launching an HTCondor cluster,
as well as running
a job on there.
So now I'd like to go
into some case studies.
So to show you the power
of HTCondor in the Cloud,
we actually have a
great case study.
So Fermilab is a
national laboratory
that does research into
high-energy particle physics.
For anybody who is not
familiar with them,
they're based near Chicago.
And so they do a lot
of work with groups
like CERN and other particle
physics and particle
accelerator groups.
And so what they did was,
at SuperComputing 2016,
during the week of the show--
on the show floor in fact--
they burst their resources
by double using Google Cloud
Platform.
So in order to accommodate
the, as you can imagine,
massive amounts of
computing that they do,
they built something called
HEPCloud, H-E-P Cloud--
High Energy Physics Cloud.
And so this cloud
is really a portal
designed to coalesce a lot of
disparate computing resources.
So they borrow computing time
from [INAUDIBLE],, and NCSA,
and a lot of large
supercomputing centers
and put it all together
in this HEPCloud
to run their jobs
since they're so large.
And they decided to
use GCP to burst.
So they actually burst in a very
traditional bursty workload--
a nine-to-five pattern, where
they see their researchers
coming in and doing their work.
And they doubled their
compute resources
from 160,000 cores to 320,000
cores during that nine-to-five
all week.
And they were able to do
this really cost effectively,
for only about $1,400 an hour,
because of the preemptible VMs
and custom machine types that we
have available on Google Cloud.
So if you'd like to learn a
little bit more about this
and see architecture diagrams
and everything like that where
they describe how they
did this, then there's
a great talk from
last year's Next
called "Large scale and batch
computing Google Compute
Engine.
That's really interesting.
They have a Fermilab
engineer there to present.
Just to give you an idea,
this is the project they did.
It's called the CMS detector.
It's basically a 14,000-ton, 1
million pixel digital camera,
and it captures about 40
million images a second.
So you can imagine the
amount of data that generates
and the amount of
processing that takes.
Another great example is our
friends, Andrew Sutherland,
at MIT.
He's a mathematics
professor and researcher.
And so he was exploring
the generalization
of hyperelliptic curves.
It's a math problem.
And so he needed a really large
amount of compute resources
to do this work.
And so MIT being MIT, they
have some HPC resources,
so he went to them
and he said, I
need a lot of nodes, a lot
of cores, to do this job,
and I need some very
specific software.
And they weren't able
to accommodate him,
so he needed to go
to Google Cloud.
And at first, as you can see
in the blog post on the bottom,
he spun up 220,000
cores for a single job.
He likes to break his own
records though I guess,
so the next job he ran, he hit
580,000 cores in a single job
using preemptible VMs.
And he did this on
32-core instances--
18,000 of them or so.
That came to about 300
core years of compute.
And he did this
using preemptible VM,
so he set up checkpointing
on the local disk
so that when the node was
preempted-- when a node is
preempted, it's just stopped.
So you can restart the node, and
if it's check-pointed to disk,
you resume from the
checkpoint, and off you go.
So very efficient way
to do that computation.
He said, "it changes your
whole outlook on research
when you can ask a question
and get an answer in hours
rather than months or weeks."
"You start to really ask
different questions,"
and that's really true.
The reason he did that
580,000-core job is because he
decided to expand his
problem space tremendously,
to not look at just
the traditional curves,
but to look at any curves.
And he got some interesting
results out of that.
So you can read more about that
in the blog post at the bottom.
So what does 300 core
years of compute time
look like in a few hours?
Well, there you have it.
And the best part of this is
that he actually launched this
on a Sunday afternoon
sitting on his back porch,
and it cost less than the amount
of money he expected it to cost
and got in his grant.
Schlumberger is
another great example.
Schlumberger, for anybody
who's not familiar with them,
is an oil and gas
exploration company.
And so they migrated
their compute resources
to Google Cloud to meet
their massive demand.
So what Schlumberger does
is really sends out ships
into the ocean with massive
trawler signal arrays and data
capture arrays, and they
use all of that data
to create visualizations
of the sea's subsurface
to find these oil deposits
and tell other people where
to drill.
And so by using their custom
machine types and NVIDIA GPUs,
they were able to hit about
35 petaflops of compute power
and 10 petabytes of storage
in Google Cloud Platform.
There's a great talk
as well from Next
'17 called "Supercharge
your performance using
GPUs in the cloud."
And during that, Ashok Belani,
the executive vice president
of technology at
Schlumberger said
they're "leveraging
the strengths offered
by cloud computation
to bring their data
processing to the next level."
And finally, we have
Silicon Therapeutics.
They're a drug
discovery company based
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
And so they shifted their
compute to run on GCP.
And they, by doing
so, were able to find
many more active compounds than
they were able to previously.
So in the blog post at the
bottom of the slide there
they said, "the biggest
benefit of using
GCP was being able
to more thoroughly
screen compounds than they
ever could have before"
with their in-house resources,
and that the massive amount
of compute resources
available in the Cloud
allowed them to find more
active compounds than they ever
would have been able
to find previously,
which means that
they can probably
find more active drugs.
So they hit about 16,000
cores in 3 million core hours
for only $30,000.
Again, this is because of
preemptible VMs and custom
machine types.
They actually used a mix of
standard and preemptible VMs,
which is very popular.
So the standard VMs were
used for the longer running
and static portions
of their jobs.
Some of those were
coordinating jobs
where they would launch
sub-jobs or minor jobs
and then coalesce
all of the results
back and launch more
jobs again off of that.
And then use preemptible VMs for
the shorter, independent jobs.
So they chose
Google Cloud because
of our Skylake processors,
our fast local SSDs,
our commitment to
open-source, and of course,
that crazy pricing.
So I'd like to offer you
guys the chance to look up
some of these blog posts and a
few more that I didn't mention
on things like satellite
image processing and genomics.
And we also have some great
talks this week at Next '18.
The top one actually
happened already,
but all of our sessions
will be recorded
and available on
YouTube very quickly--
actually, yesterday's
sessions are available today.
But we do have two
more coming up.
So "Research Workloads
on Preemptible VMs"
is about doing computing
on preemptible VMs,
really taking advantage of them.
And that's with one of
our product managers
and a couple of people from
Two Sigma, a financial services
customer.
As well as "Computing
with Power Not Previously
Possible with BigQuery
and Compute Engine."
This is actually touching
on Slurm specifically.
So SUNY Downstate Medical
Center and University
of South Carolina are using
Slurm auto-scaling clusters
in the Cloud to run their
neuroscience research
and genomics research,
respectively.
And they'll be talking
on a panel tomorrow.
So that's all I had.
Does anybody have any questions?
If not, please dig into those
codelabs labs and tutorials
and have fun.
[MUSIC PLAYING]